they are probably gonna go crazy he's
Kylie Jenner throwing shade at someone
literally need to ask her that is gonna
be my next question on our group chat
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
posted adorable pictures of her and her
daughter's stormy in the first photo
Kylie and her little one are sharing a
sweet kiss the second snap shows the
makeup mogul looking flawless while
lifting stormy up but it's the third pic
that caught everyone's attention the
mother-daughter duo looking fierce
rocking matching sunglasses with a
message saying don't talk to me or my
daughter ever again
dance thinks she's sending this message
to her ex Travis Scott others believe it
might be towards her former assistant
Victoria after reports claims she quit
her job to become an influencer it's fun
though it's fun but earlier this week
Victoria set the record straight
she toasted on Instagram I worked with
Kylie for five years and she became one
of my closest friends we both decided it
was time to grow without each other
professionally about a year ago she's
still one of my best friends in a
relationship has only gotten stronger
it's clear though right but guys it
might not be that serious
Kylie may be mocking the popular meme
don't talk to me or my son ever again
I'm definitely like eight feet away we
are living for this mother-daughter duo
[Music]